[Applause]
i don't know why it's difficult for me
but give it up everybody for hans kim
[Applause]
one non-famous person
one famous person
one for you one for me okay
prepare for some community service
you guys are all gonna write this up on
your taxes next year
i'm like dogecoin
we're investing
in my future
uh i'm really funny
i uh i think it's funny that uh tanner
is a white person's name i mean tanner
and what
is my mexican friend tanner
that's my black friend tanist
i don't even see race i only smell it
especially those brown ones
[Music]
but uh
i uh
i was on an airplane and i saw a dude
reading a book in arabic which kind of
freaked me out
oh thank god it's my future plans
[Music]
the other people in mexico before they
go to america their friends were like oh
you're going to america you know you can
drink the shower water over there
my sister is actually a very good
christian woman she just got back from a
mission trip if you don't know that is
that's where americans go to develop
countries to get new profile pictures
[Applause]
that's right
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
she's like did you know that your toilet
water is clean and they're drinking
water in africa
those are the pipes that we have we pipe
it in what do you want me to do about it
like pipes to make it feel better
let me see african walking down the
street i let him drink from my toilet
it's not a problem
it's flush afterwards i don't want any
days
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
king junior malcolm x harry and thomas
and marshall george washington
uh
now there's a fake person that dresses
like a cat
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what are they congratulations come out
with our movie the yellow panda
just gonna eat your furniture
it's a little bit steady
go get them on a roll
[Applause]
oh that's great thanks for coming
you're great
that's harriet
uh but i love comedy sometimes i'm sure
as a painter because i've never been
painting a picture and had a canvas be
like
[Music]
draw something asian
i am asian resident of this country i'm
chinese
province in china called south korea
[Applause]
i love being asian a lot of people are
shocked that we eat dogs which i
understand can be very shocking because
in america doctors dream like family
members but making sure we shoot your
family members like family members
it's this real little tradition we have
in the motherland where instead of
buying an animal we love our grandma
should everyone better in asia unless
you're a baby
[Music]
look how fast your ball trains go
so i love being asian because uh i can
walk into a starbucks and tell them that
my name is ching chong bing bong the
third
[Applause]
what are they going to do that's not
your name
excuse me i come from a long line of
bing bongs
my asian friends make fun of me because
i like to eat general says chicken
like isn't genesis chicken just a shitty
and recognized version of something
authentically asian
i was like yeah so am i
[Applause]
my favorite movie is rush hour 3.
i love being here in texas
[Applause]
i'm also a southerner because i'm from
south korea
we share a lot of similarities
[Applause]
there's only two things i like shooting
commies and k-pop
[Applause]
here in texas
uh i love rednecks because rednecks can
survive in any wilderness situation that
you put them in except a situation where
everyone has equal
[Applause]
you can rights in a swamp with an
alligator why can't you live in a cold
side with a minority
[Applause]
try smiling
relax a little
but uh
[Applause]
i think the confederate flag is uh very
uh insensitive okay
i think the confederate flag would be
like if a man went up to his wife and i
said hey honey remember that time we
went into that huge argument and i'm
trying to divorce you
pretty proud that time
[Applause]
it represents who i am as a person
so i got a divorce papers tattooed on my
chest
very intense sir
but um i i'm not religious uh i grew up
christian as an asian person which is
kind of weird because the people wrote
the bible didn't even seem to know that
asians existed
i i'm an atheist now because i'm not a
kindergarten and i have an internet
connection
i think it'd be stressful to have an
ideology that could be destroyed by
facts
like on a hike like oh look apostle [ __ ]
i guess i could have been blowing dudes
this whole time
i am not gay
uh
i don't think i can ever [ __ ] dudes i've
never looked at a beautiful woman and
they're like wow is there a version of
her that's bigger and hairier
please believe me my dad doesn't
[Applause]
my friends are always like dude you need
to learn how to talk to women
maybe or maybe women should learn how to
listen to hans
why don't you want to hear about the
federal reserve
this one girl was like hey did you know
that my vagina can make a baby so
technically my vagina is a 3d printer i
was like
actually your womb is a 3d printer your
vagina
[Applause]
it only means one thing with lots of
errors
[Applause]
takes nine months to print
[Applause]
it is to say i did not see any trays
that night
i love the ladies but i get in trouble
for staring at them in public because to
me a beautiful lady is like a scenic
sunset that can yell at you
they'll go downside they can call cops
i am an asian man so you know it's hard
for me to date
uh
women are beautiful but how do you think
asian women are created
don't do their hard work
don't give diamonds
unless you under pressure you know it's
like uh
how do you like
uh you know
if you have sex with me and children
will be very beautiful
half of them
the other half will be great engineers
i hate asian women
sorry
i hate you guys
asian women they act like they're so
much hotter than asian men but they look
exactly the same
[Applause]
why are you bragging that you can throw
white dudes
[Applause]
[Music]
very much
[Applause]